-Our guests tonight
are three of
my favorite people
in the world.
Please welcome back
to our annual Thanksgiving show
my family -- Hillary,
Larry and Josh Meyers.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, everybody.
The Meyers family.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, this is very
exciting because last year,
obviously COVID was
in a far worse place
and we basically decided
a few days out
we would all stay at home.
You guys were in New Hampshire,
two different rooms.
Josh, you were in L.A.
[ Laughter ]
It's very nice
to be here in person.
I think they think two different
rooms is where --
You are sometimes
in the same room.
-Yes.
-It goes better when you're not.
[ Laughter ]
And, Josh, the scariest thing
that happened
was we were we were in Zooming
and you decided to do
your interview from the bathtub.
-Yeah, I decided --
Well, I was in my house
and I was like,
change of venue,
change of location
for the second act or third act,
whatever you want to call.
Yeah.
-And then while you were
Zooming in a bathtub, you froze.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And there was a fear
amongst all of us here
that you had electrocuted
yourself in the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, which is a valid fear.
You know I've got
a lighting kit set up
and I've got a computer.
-A lot of things tipping on
the side of a bathtub ledge.
-Yeah.
-Was it scary for you
in the moment?
-No, just the lights went out.
-Yeah.
-The lights went out
and I didn't know
if it was just, like,
my Internet or my apartment,
and I didn't want to
get out of the tub
because my bubbles were gone.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-In case the power
kicked back on...
-Right, at an inopportune
moment.
-Right.
-Not only is this show canceled,
but you personally
are canceled.
[ Laughter ]
-Or not.
It's weird.
It's weird who gets canceled
and who doesn't these days.
-I think the bummer is you were
in the middle of a story
when you got frozen.
So let's just show that clip.
-Sure.
-And then just pick it up
right when it gets frozen
and finish the story for us.
-Okay, yeah.
I get on the couch.
I would get a warm blanket
wrapped around me.
I'd be given a bagel with cream
cheese and bacon and juice.
And I would watch
"The Smurfs" and "The Snorks."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, every every morning
I was woken up.
And she would have drawn
a bath for me,
and that's how my love
of baths was created.
-So, I feel
like having a full 12 months
between the middle
and the end of the story
probably hurt it a little.
-Probably a little bit, yeah.
-We also talked last year
about how the next time
you were going to see our boys,
my boys,
that you were going to dress up
like the White Rabbit
from "Alice in Wonderland."
And I had my doubts
that you would do that.
-That's disappointing to hear.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, no one was disappointed
on the day.
Take a look. I should --
If you like cute videos,
there's going
to be a fair share today.
Take a look at this one.
-Panka Yarry's late.
-I'm late for
a very important date!
No time to say "Hello", goodbye!
I'm late! I'm late!
I'm overdue!
I'm in a rabbit stew!
No time to say "Hello," goodbye!
I'm late, I'm late, I'm late,
I'm late, I'm late!
I'm late for
a very important date!
No time to say "Hello," goodbye!
I'm late, I'm late, I'm late!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now...
Over the course
of this past year,
you're not a man
who rests on your laurels.
So, you knock out White Rabbit.
Then the kids get into Babar.
He shows up.
[ Audience aws ]
And then the Flash.
The Flash showed up.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-And you wouldn't believe
how crazy fast he was.
-Oh, my God, this is --
Yeah, it doesn't look it.
But this is exactly as fast as
the fastest Flash.
[ Laughter ]
-Ain't no Flash like a Flash
with a stache.
[ Laughter ]
-Ain't no Flash like a Flash
with a stache.
Now, we have another because --
You explain how it first --
Do you remember
how it first started,
what Dad decides to do
as he pulled into the driveway?
-Oh, the honking business?
-Yes.
-Yes, well, I think it was
Pittsburgh had that honk --
bum, bum, bum-bum-bum.
-When we were in high school,
when we would pull up
to our friends
to let them know
we were out there,
we would always honk
a certain way.
There were some
high school fraternities
and we called it a Pi Tau.
And we used to go
dah, dah, dah-dah-dah,
and then you would always know
it was
one of your friends for you.
-Well, now my kids know.
They get so excited
when they hear it.
And this is a series
over the course of the last year
of my boys hearing the honk.
And I should note,
the last part of this clip
is you guys leaving.
And it's a slightly
different reaction.
Also, I forgot to preface,
for those who don't know this,
my kids call my parents
Panka Yarry and Panka Hurry.
Panka was how my oldest son
said grandpa, and it stuck.
So take a look at the Pankas
arriving.
[ Horn honking rhythmically,
kids laughing ]
[ Horn honking rhythmically ]
-[ Laughing ]
-Ah! Aaah! Aaah!
[ Honking continues ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Kids screaming ]
-Hi! Hi!
That's the Flash, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
-Say bye, guys.
-Bye!
[ Audience aws ]
-[ Cries ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They seem to be fans.
They seem to be fans.
We want everybody
to stick around
because up next,
we have,
I guess, I think you can call it
a surprise announcement,
which I think will be
very fun for everybody.
We'll be right back with more
Hillary, Larry, Josh
and a surprise
Meyers family announcement.